-Welcome to "Late Night."
Today, the president
reeled off an unhinged rant
in a call with governors,
demanding that they dominate
protesters with mass arrests
after days of violent police
escalation and unrest
over the murder of George Floyd.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
-President Trump has been
quietly hunkered down
in the White House, occasionally
threatening wild fantasies
of violence against protesters
and belching out random
all-caps tweets, like,
"FAKE NEWS!"
And "LAW AND ORDER!"
We're in the middle
of a national crisis,
and he tweets like he's yelling
at his Roku
to change the channel.
[ As Trump ] Law and order!
Below deck! Playboy Channel!
Uh, Mnuchin, we need to pay
for the Playboy Channel.
[ Normal voice ] And then today,
Trump reeled off
a deranged screed in a call
with governors
where he sounded like a cross
between a brutal military
dictator
and a racist grandpa shuffling
around the nursing home
with his robe on backwards.
-President Trump today
venting frustration
at some of the nation's
governors.
In a conference call,
the president
was at the White House.
The president calling governors
"weak,"
saying they need a more robust
police response
to the protests going on now
across the country.
-President Trump is criticizing
the nation's governors
for being "fools" in their
response to violent protests.
The "Associated Press"
quotes Trump as saying,
"Most of you are weak.
You have to arrest people and
put them in jail for 10 years
and you'll never see this stuff
again."
-He said, "You have to dominate.
If you don't dominate,
you're wasting your time.
They're going to run over you.
You're going to look like
a bunch of jerks.
You have to dominate."
-They look like jerks?
You're the one who's been
cowering in the White House
with the lights off.
I mean, look at that.
That's our White House.
Right now, Donald Trump is going
from room to room
telling people to act like
they're not home
if the doorbell rings.
[ As Trump ]
Nobody answer the door.
I'm two weeks behind
on the rent.
We used the money
for the Playboy Channel.
[ Normal voice ] The White House
has turned into the weird
abandoned house at the end of
the neighborhood the kids
dare each other to break into
on Halloween.
"They say old man Trump still
lives up there in the attic
with a corpse!"
"I'm not a corpse,
Mr. President."
[ As Trump ] Shut up, corpse,
they'll hear you!
If you had any doubts at all
about the dangers
of our overly militarized
police culture,
those doubts were answered.
In the response
to the nationwide protests
over the murder of George Floyd,
over the last few days,
we've all seen numerous examples
of police
being needlessly violent
or escalating their encounters
with protesters and reporters
for no legitimate purpose.
Like the many scenes of police
violently shoving people
to the ground or the police SUV
that drove into a crowd
in New York, or the officer
in Louisville
who just casually launched
what appeared to be pepper balls
at a local TV reporter covering
the scene from a distance.
The police can't even get
through protests
against police brutality
without committing
more police brutality.
It's like if your wife
accused you of having an affair
in divorce court, and you tried
to smooth it over
by seducing the judge.
"Look, the only question I have,
your honor,
is what's under that robe?"
Even just showing up to
a protest in riot gear
with military equipment
is a form of escalation,
which we saw in cities
across the country,
like, for example,
in Columbia, South Carolina.
Ask yourself, why do local
police departments have tanks
when doctors and nurses
can't even get masks and gowns?
We spend billions on military
equipment for police
and healthcare workers
have to wear snorkel masks
like retirees on vacation
in the Caribbean.
There are teachers in this
country who are drowning in debt
and have to spend
their own money
to buy supplies
for their classrooms.
If anyone deserves a tank,
it's them.
If you pulled up to your
high school and saw a tank
parked in the math teacher's
spot,
you'd learn what
a [bleep] fractal is.
I still don't know,
'cause mine drove a Subaru.
And in some cases,
the police excuses
for aggressively escalating
the violence
have just been in absurd.
Like in Louisville,
where police fired tear gas
at a peaceful protest
and claimed that it was
because police saw people
approaching
that had leaf-blowers
loaded with bleach
that was intended
to blow at police,
so they sent out the tear gas.
First of all, in their defense,
they may have just heard
the president speak
and then loaded up their
leaf-blowers with bleach
to cure corona.
"Open your mouths, everybody,
the worst is over!"
Vrrrrrrrrrrrrr!
And second, a leaf-blower
loaded with bleach
sounds like something
Kevin McCallister would use
against Harry and Marv.
Were you also afraid
the protesters
would use a barbecue starter
to heat up a doorknob
or drop a tarantula
onto your face?
Even elected officials were not
immune from police violence,
as a New York state
assemblywoman, Diana Richardson,
explained after getting
pepper-sprayed
at a protest in Brooklyn.
-The NYPD is being excessively
aggressive
with this crowd here,
and it is inappropriate!
I'm Assemblywoman
Diana Richardson.
I'm an elected official,
and they just pepper-sprayed me
for no reason!
And if anyone knows the law,
trust me, I know it.
We were only peacefully
assembling.
-You know, if you're going
to pepper spray
a group of peaceful protesters
unprovoked,
you might want to make sure
those protesters don't know
more about the law than you do.
It's like trying to sell a
reverse mortgage to Tom Selleck.
[ As Selleck ]
Nice try, those are just a trick
to take your house.
Or like trying to sell
a used car to Dom Toretto.
"Trust me, the Dodge Dart,
fastest car on the market."
[ As Toretto ] It's not about
speed. It's about family."
Did not use a second
of my week off
to work on my Vin Diesel
impression.
The police, like the rest of us,
are supposed to be governed
by civilians
through a democratic process.
They should never be seen
as above the process
because then that means
they're above accountability.
Civilian political leadership
are supposed to exercise
authority over the police
and hold them accountable
for abuses of power, just like
they would anyone else.
Yet as we've seen in
New York City just this weekend,
too many of our leaders
have simply acquiesced
that authority.
-New York City Police
are investigating this video
showing an NYPD cruiser ram into
a crowd during a protest.
You can see the cruiser
behind a barrier
shortly after protesters began
throwing objects on Saturday.
The cruisers
sort of lurches forward.
No word yet on any injuries.
New York mayor Bill de Blasio
refused to blame the officers,
saying he found the video
troubling,
but the protesters
did the wrong thing
to surround that police vehicle
and threaten the officers.
-I saw a lot of restraint
under very, very difficult
circumstances.
Clearly, we need to do
a full investigation
and look at the actions
of those officers
and see what was done
and why it was done
and what could be done
differently.
I don't ever want to see a
police officer do that, period.
Period. Ever.
But I also know that there was
an extremely dangerous
situation,
and the one thing they couldn't
do was stay there.
-They could have just reversed.
I mean,
they should know how to drive.
They're cops, not Billy Joel.
If you don't get that joke,
don't worry, it just means
you're under 50.
Congratulations on your youth.
I know de Blasio doesn't drive
because he's so tall,
his head would
stick out of the sunroof.
But he should know that cars
can go forwards and backwards.
So the police have cracked down
with impunity
on protests across the country.
And yet, for a few soulless,
right-wing cable news husks,
that's not enough.
-When you express an opinion
our leaders don't like,
they call it violence!
When criminals commit
actual acts of violence,
they call it speech.
So, the game is rigged.
Why are the rest of us
still playing it?
None of the thugs looting Target
or the well-paid nihilists
on television
who are egging them on
have added a thing. Nothing.
Should you keep playing along
with all of that?
Ponder that the next time
they demand you get a permit
to put a deck on your own house.
-We all saw a man get murdered
by police
while begging for his life,
and your biggest concern
is putting a deck on your house?
Are you an actual person
or just a monogrammed towel
come to life?
We're in the middle
of an economic crisis
that has put 40-million people
out of work.
And this human penny loafer
thinks the average American's
biggest concern right now
is whether to go with redwood
or cedar.
Of course, it makes sense since
Mr. Faux Populism over here
always looks like the waiter
at his country club
just told him they were out
of foie gras.
But sadly, he's not alone.
The president has repeatedly
threatened violence,
called for governors
to dominate protesters,
and insisted on law and order.
But in reality,
the kind of order
people like Trump
or Tucker revere
is an order that only serves
them.
They insist
that communities of color
politely and obediently
request change
from a system that systemically
ignores, dehumanizes,
and disenfranchises them.
We saw that on display
yet again this week
with the rampant acts
of police escalation.
And we know it's not necessary,
because just a few weeks ago,
police were physically
confronted
by angry right-wing protesters
calling for an end to lockdowns.
And oddly, they seemed to have
left their tanks
and tear gas at home.
Man, I haven't seen white people
that angry
since "Frasier"
went off the air.
Granted,
different white people.
This was more
of a "Storage Wars" crowd.
And yet, in contrast to the
restraint police showed there,
we have seen one video after
another over the last few days
in which police needlessly
escalated encounters
with protesters, reporters,
and bystanders
for no legitimate purpose.
And in the face of that,
the very least we can do,
the absolute minimum
is to acknowledge
that there is a deeply rooted
systemic problem here.
We can't just gloss over it
with the same old excuses.
For example, we have to stop
saying [bleep] like this.
-George Floyd is hardly
the only unarmed black American
killed recently by police.
Do you think systemic racism
is a problem in law enforcement
agencies in the United States?
-No, I don't think
there's systemic racism.
I think 99.9% of our
law enforcement officers
are great Americans.
But you know what?
There are some bad apples
in there.
Because there's a few bad apples
that are giving law enforcement
a terrible name,
and there's no doubt that
there's some racist police.
I think they're the minority.
I think they're
the few bad apples.
-Stop saying the problem
is just a few bad apples.
It's not an apple problem.
It's an orchard problem.
If you went apple picking
and the guy who ran the orchard
said "There are a few bad apples
out there."
And you asked, "How bad?"
And they said, "Kill you bad."
You'd say,
"This is a bad orchard."
And now is not the time
to complain about it,
but apple picking [bleep] sucks.
Let's just all agree on that.
Why are apples the only food
people want to pick
for themselves?
They all look the same.
And it's not even a challenge.
They're just dangling there.
You know what would be
more exciting?
Catching your own turkey.
Then the best part about coming
home for Thanksgiving would be
your mom serving, I don't know,
Thanksgiving spaghetti
while your dad mutters
about his busted ankle.
"They're faster than you think.
Tell you that much.
They look slow, but they --
they move."
Putting it on a few bad apples
ignores the reality
that there's a predatory system
with a history
of police misconduct
built on a legacy of racism
and exploitation
that elevates the comfort
and security of white people
over the health and safety
of black people.
This -- This is why we can't
just settle for mild reforms.
Yes, we must demand
accountability,
but we can't stop there.
We need systemic change,
and that extends to everything
from healthcare
to housing to poverty.
Just look at how our emphasis on
policing skews our priorities.
New York City, for example,
spends more on policing
than it does on the departments
of health, homeless services,
housing preservation
and development,
and youth and community
development combined.
New York spends all that money
on police,
and yet, apparently, their cars
don't even come with reverse.
They should get a tip from
[ As Vin Diesel ]
me, Vin Diesel.
Now, see? It's getting --
Maybe New York could start
to put some of that money aside
for things like healthcare,
housing,
and signs at the top
of escalators
that tell tourists,
"Do not stand here."
I mean, that sign alone could
prevent 100 assaults a year.
As a society, we spend more
on the systems
that punish and devalue
black lives
than we do on the things that
reaffirm and empower black lives
and allow people to live lives
of safety, decency, and health.
We have to invest in things
like housing and healthcare.
And we need laws restricting
the use of force,
demilitarizing the police,
and investing in nonviolent
alternatives to the police.
We know these policies can work.
We just need leaders
who will talk about them
and who will talk about the ways
we can begin to dismantle
the interlocking systems
of racism and injustice
that perpetuate police violence.
Instead, our president
has been cowering
in the White House
with the lights off.
100,000 Americans have died
in a public health crisis
that has disproportionately
preyed on communities of color.
40-million people have lost
their jobs
in an economic collapse
that has ravaged the poor
and working class.
The murder of yet another
unarmed black man
at the hands of police
has sparked a level of unrest
this country hasn't seen
in our lifetimes.
And the lights were off
at the White House.
But honestly, I would take that
over Trump talking.
I mean,
what could he possibly say?
We all know where he stands.
He praised Nazis and armed
white protesters in Michigan
while denouncing black people
as thugs,
threatening them with vicious
dogs and ominous weapons,
and quoting a racist
police chief from the 1960s,
which, by the way,
is just insane.
The guy can't spell his wife's
name or his own name,
but when it comes
to racist slogans,
he's like Little Man Tate.
That one is for anyone
who's over 40.
So, if you've got one,
if you got Little Man Tate,
but not Billy Joel,
you're in your 40s.
It's impossible to think
of a worse person
to inhabit the most powerful
office in the country right now.
Trump has been hiding away
in the White House
tweeting out wild fantasies
of violence,
telling governors
to dominate protesters,
and declaring,
without any apparent
constitutional authority,
that he's designating Antifa,
which isn't even a formal group,
a terrorist organization.
There's a good chance
he doesn't even know
it stands for "antifascist."
He probably thinks
it's a person.
[ As Trump ]
Aunt Ifa, terrorist,
and I'm not too fond of her
husband, Uncle Ifa, either.
[ Normal voice ] So, you'd be
forgiven for watching all this
and thinking that something
fundamental in America is broken
and that it's been broken
for a long time.
Or as Cornel West put it...
-We are witnessing America
as a failed social experiment.
What I mean by that is that
the history of black people
for over 200 some years
and in America
has been looking at America's
failure.
Its capitalist economy
could not generate
and deliver in such a way
that people could live lives
of decency.
The nation state,
its criminal justice system,
its legal system could not
generate protection
of rights and liberties.
But the question is,
we must fight,
even in a moment in which we
have a failed social experiment.
-Speaking of failed experiments,
our president
looks like something from
a 1980s teen movie
where two high schoolers
attach electrodes to a potato
and a confederate flag
to make him come to life.
But even in the face of failure,
we have to keep fighting.
We have to reaffirm every day
that black lives matter.
And we have to work to dismantle
the interconnected systems
of racism and injustice
that devalue and disenfranchise
those lives.
This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
Now more than ever, City Harvest
has been stepping up
to rescue and deliver more food
to meet the increased need
in New York City.
If you're watching this online,
you can hit the donate button.
Stay safe, wash your hands,
we love you.